hello everyone and welcome to the tie
breaks of the fourth round of the video
World Cup between Magnus Carlsen and
Vincent kaimer uh as you know uh when
the two classical games are drawn or one
player wins one and the other player
wins the other one they go into tie
breaks and then they have to see who is
better now first they're gonna play two
rapid games with 25 minutes per player
then if it's a draw they're gonna play
two more rapid games with 10 minutes per
player then they're gonna play two Blitz
Games with five minutes per player and
if even that is a draw they're gonna
play two Blitz Games with three minutes
per player and if that's a draw they're
going to go into Armageddon so uh this
is the first rapid game and that we're
also going to show the second rapid game
in this video so let's check it out it's
Magnus with the white pieces in the
first game and he opens with Pawn to D4
even though he got a win with E4 in the
classical game he opts for D4 with
Knight F6 C4 E6 and now Knight to F3 we
have Pawn to D5 and now C captures on D5
we have e captures and Knight to C3 just
a nice change duration of the Queen's
gamma decline with C6 and now Queen to
C2 something Magnus off in place he
played it against alirez that he played
against Yani pomnishi and it's a very
very solid line with Bishop D7 by
Vincent Bishop to F4 and now Pawn to G6
preparing to play Bishop to F5 to kick
away the White Queen so Magnus of course
has to get ready for this E3 he will
block it with Bishop to D3 Bishop F5
attacks the Queen Bishop to D3 blocks
and now we have a trade captures
captures and Knight B to D7 uh we have
Pawn to H4 uh the move that Magnus also
played uh against Levon Aryan although
he lost that game uh it was in a Norway
chess 2020 and Lavon won a very nice
game with the black pieces but in that
game uh Ponte A5 was played by Levon uh
here we have Queen to A5 by Vincent and
it is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so how does Magnus
deal with this spin he plays King to F1
he says I will not be castling I'm going
after your king So Okay Ponte H5
everything gets ready for that and now
Pawn to G3 we have Castles by Vincent
and now King to G2 we have Rook f the E8
and now Knight to G5 just putting stuff
in front of Vincent's King and now
Knights to f8 so again Magnus a little
bit better on clock he has 25 minutes
events in some 17 minutes on the clock
and we have Pawn to A3 of course
preparing B4 so Vincent goes back with
the queen to help out with the defense
and also to play A5 to stop magnus's B4
now he could play right away but he
doesn't he plays Rook HD1 first with A5
now since Magnus did not play before
Vincent stops it and now Rook 8 to D1
sort of in the style of the Old Masters
putting Rooks on D1 and E1 uh we have
Knight 8 the H7 and now Magnus trades
one of the knights Knight captures on H7
and now you could play Knight captures
on H7 but then uh the Knight no longer
keeps around the E4 Square so Vincent
goes King captures on H7 and Magnus
still goes for Pawn to E4 maybe slow
playing this with F3 controlling the
Knight is the way to go but Magnus
decides to go uh straight uh straight
forward the characters we have Knight
captures and now Queen to D5 a Vincent
neutralizes the position now uh the
Knight cannot move Magnus plays Queen to
F3 to unlock this pin and now Knight
captures on e4 Rook captures an E4 and
now Bishop to f8 again going for further
trades we have Rook captures 98 and now
Rook captures an E8 capturing the queen
here doesn't really do all that much for
Vincent because it improves the position
of magnus's King and now for example if
row captures you just get D5 a bit more
easily let's see see characters real
characters and now this Rook is very
nice going after A5 going after B7 uh so
you don't want to do this so I have to
root capture 78 Rook capture Sunny it by
Vincent and now comes Queen captures on
D5 we have C captures and now Rook to C1
and as usual Magnus doing much better on
time he has 20 minutes on the clock of
instant only six minutes on the clock
and uh you should definitely go for a
move like Rook to E2 it's a very
powerful idea just putting the Rook on
the same and rank also putting pressure
on V2 another idea might be a rook to E6
going for Rook to B6 then putting
pressure on B2 but Vincent goes for none
of that he plays Bishop to G7 first goes
after the D4 Pawn but Magnus thrilled to
see this he plays Bishop to E3 which
blocks the threat of Bishop captures and
D4 and also prevents the infiltration of
The Rook via the E2 Square so okay Rook
to E4 Vincent will win the D4 Pawn but
Magnus has other Pawns in mind Rook to
C5 with Bishop captures and D5 Bishop
captures and The Rook captures on D5 we
have real characters on A5 and now Pawn
to F6 there is no way to defend the B7
Pawn we have Rook to B5 and now Pawn to
G5 now Vincent will have to play this
rook and pawn end game being down upon
against Magnus Carlsen Rook captures on
B7 King to G6 and now Rook to B4 Magnus
goes for uh for trade here it's a very
strange he he didn't go for trade
captures captures and then Pawn to B4
which is definitely the way to go he
played Rook B for first and now Rook to
D1 uh we have King to F3 and now comes
King to F5 Vincent finds very nice moves
here King the E2 attacks the rook and
The Rook the B1 of course you have to
put the rule behind the pass pawn and A4
Magnus starts advancing the pawn
uh G captures on H4 G captures and now
Rook the A1 now putting the rule behind
the past a pawn and here we have King to
E3 advancing the king forward with King
the E5 and now uh we have pawned the F4
with check by Magnus and this is the
move that allows Vincent back into the
game uh as uh well it's not a very
precise move the problem for Magnus I
believe was as he had 15 minutes on the
clock Vincent had only some 30 seconds
on the clock and it wasn't
um it wasn't the way to go instead of
this F4 move what magnet should have
played is F3 just slowly build up your
position it'll maybe allow a few checks
let's say rookie one checking to D3
sorry uh King to D3 are gonna play Rook
back day one and after B3 okay now let's
say Rook 32 because Vincent does not
have a move here now you play Rook to B5
and you slowly start pushing that pawn
to A5 Pawn to B4 and so on there's
always time to play fonte F4 and win
that B5 Pawn no need to Russian but
Magnus played Ponte F4 check right away
and now comes King to F5 and now King to
D4 we have King to G4 and now King
captures on D5 we have King characters
and H4 and now King the E6 with King to
G3 by Vincent now he is also ready to
start pushing his passport to Victory
King characters on F6 and now Pawn to H4
we have Pawn to F5 and pawn to H3 now
you can see that there is no way to stop
the pawn other than to give up The Rook
King to G5 H2 and now Rook the H4 and of
course Vincent plays a rook captures an
A4 he tries to give up The Rook for uh
the uh the H1 Square he wants the queen
but Magnus just plays The Rook captures
on H2 he gives up a full Rook but the
past Pawn will also Force Vincent to
give up his Rook so Pawn to F6 and now
King to G3 Vincent still has to be very
careful as per he's pretty much the only
one who can still lose this Ponte F7 and
now Rook the F4 of course now Vincent is
also ready to give up his Rook for the
past spawn King 6 King to F3 and now
King to G6 Now The Rook guards against
this Pawn the king will of course stop
the b-pawn and that's pretty much it
with King to E4 and now f8 Queen Vincent
of course has to give up his Rook Magnus
captures King to D4 and now Magnus plays
Pawn to B3 King to C3 and now Pawn to B4
that's uh some 20 moves too late to play
Pawn to B4 as it was winning in many of
the other lines King captures on B4 and
it is a draw on move 55 by insufficient
material so this is what happened in the
first game of the rapid uh match now
let's check out what happened in the
second game where of course Vincent had
the white pieces now this one it's just
absolutely incredible so hope you guys
are ready for this uh Vincent opens with
Pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6 by
Magnus uh C4 with E6 Knights the C3 and
Bishop to B4 already we are treated to a
nice nimzo Indian defense by Magnus
Ponte F3 the Mohawk variation and now
Knight to C6 we have Pawn to E4 and now
D5 is the standard move here Magnus goes
for Ponte E5 instead also very much
playable A3 attacks the bishop of Bishop
captures B captures and the pawn to D6
now we have Knight to E2 and pawn to B6
now preparing the fincato the light
Square Bishop Knights to G3 and now
there is a game where castles was played
but here we have Knight to A5 and it is
now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game so the standard
stuff Knight comes to E5 will put
pressure on the C4 Pawn uh and uh C5 is
coming Bishop to B7 is coming the usual
names of Indian stuff so Bishop to D3 we
have Pawn to H5 by Magnus now saying
that he also is interested in attacking
on the king side as he tried in the
previous game castles and now Pawn to H4
by Magnus we have Knight to F5 and
Magnus happily trades captures captures
and now Queen to D7 but here uh Vincent
is doing much better on time he's down
to 20 minutes and Magnus uh down to some
22 minutes on the clock we have Rook to
B1 1 and now Queen side Castles by
Magnus with Bishop to G5 putting
pressure on the Knight here pinning the
Knight basically and pawn to C5 not too
worried about opening up the position of
his King uh which could be a little bit
dangerous so while Vincent could try to
open up the position he decides to go
for Pawn to D5 instead uh Rook to H5
attacking the bishop but Vincent again
plays the absolute best pawn to F4 now
defends the bishop and asks Magnus to
capture on F4 so he can play Bishop
captures on F4 we have Rook H back to h8
and now F captures an E5 D captures and
queen to E1 now putting pressure on the
H4 pawn and also on the E4 Pawn E5 pawn
and here is where Magnus finds this
beautiful beautiful country idea uh
Ponte E4 and now how do you react to
this well Vincent says all right I'm
gonna capture on F6 and then on e4 but
you you can't really do that Vincent
does capture here but now Magnus plays
Rook Dita E8 and both of the Bishops are
still hanging so now now it's time to
decide which one to move of course
you're not going to allow G captures on
F6 and giving magnets the semi-openg
file to attack you will play Bishop
captures on G7 and uh well defend your
your Bishop on G7 with a move like Fawn
to F6 so e captures on D3 we have Queen
to D2 and now Rook H the G8 Vincent
plays Pawn to F6 now Vincent is down to
nine minutes Magnus is down to 14
minutes on the clock and now there are
two two really really awesome moves here
one is Knight captures and E4 the other
is Rook to E2 which one do you think
Magnus went for
uh let's uh let's discuss Knight
captures on C4 attacks the queen queen
captures on D3 and now Knight E5 attacks
the queen queen F5 you have to offer a
queen trade and now you just trade
queens and go Knight D3 the game
continues with chances for both sides on
the other hand if you don't play for
Knight captures on C4 you could also go
for the mating attack but it still
doesn't quite work Queen characters on
the three Queen G4 threatens Checkmate
there's again Queen F5 check now you
have to again trade captures captures
Knight captures on C4 and we get a very
similar idea so Magnus finds a way how
to complicate things and he plays Rook
to E4 and now Vincent is uh well left
with this position and so many moves
being possible and he doesn't go for the
absolute best one you have to play Queen
captures on D3 and just allow magnets to
continue with his plan of doubling
Brooks on the E file but here Vincent
went for Rook beat the E1 and now Magnus
has a winning position but look at this
Rook captures an E1 Rook captures and
now Magnus played The Rook the EA the
winning idea here was Queen to F5 this
defends the pawn on D3 and also
threatens Knight captures and C4 which
will dislodge the queen and if you play
Queen F2 now you just trade let's say
Captain's captors and now you pick up
the pawn here and that's pretty much it
uh very much a winning position for
black however Magnus played Rook to E8
and now Vincent goes for Rook to E7 this
is much much better than Rook capture 78
so rookie 7 Rook captures F captures
Queen captures on E7 and now Queen
captures on D3 so you can see how it's a
much different position where a Magnus
lost the D3 Pawn the Knight cannot
capture and see for as opposed to what
we've just discussed Queen to E1 with
check Queen to F1 Winston blocks this
and queen to E3 checking ovens and
doesn't want to draw Vincent wants to
fight King to H1 we have Queen to E4 now
ready to pick up on C4 and the H3 of
course H3 is also an idea the g-pawn
would be pinned so Pawn to H3 and now
Ponte F5 starting to advance the fast
pawn and he of instant needs to create a
blockhead on the F4 square but he
doesn't he plays Queen to F3 and now he
offers Magnus a queenless end game with
a winning position for Magnus Queen
captures an F3 G captures and Knight
captures on C4 and now look at this uh
how is the bishop to help out with the
defense uh of the of the pushing of
Pawns on the queen side there is no way
to do it Vincent plays Pawn to A4 but
now Magnus plays King to D7 with Bishop
to F6 and now King to D6 Magnus misses a
very a very awesome win here with Ponte
A5 problem is that after Bishop captures
you have B5 and after captures you have
A4 and there's no way to stop the pawn
the bishop is helpless here
on this diagonal that's just the the
king very easily stops the fast b-pawn
uh completely winning for Magnus but
when Magnus went for King to D6 Bishop
captures an H4 and King characters on D5
Bishop to d8 by Vincent and now Knights
the B2 so make no mistake this is still
completely winning for Magnus but you
have to play precise moves H4 King to E6
H5 and now Knight captures on A4 we have
Pawn to C4 not allowing the final
capture and now King to F7 we have King
to G2 and now Knights the B2 and now the
past a pawn can finally start marching
forward of course not just yet as the
b-pawn would hang so King to G3 and now
Knight captures and C4 wheel King to F4
and pawn to B5 now with King characters
on F5 and now Pawn to B4 uh Magnus
doesn't make a mistake from the previous
game he plays that B4 move King to E4
and now Magnus plays Ponte A5 which
allows Vincent back into the game the
way to win this is spawn to B3 and now
after King the D3 which seemingly stops
the pawn now you play Pawn to A5 and now
a for A3 and that's it you cannot
capture the Knight because B2 and the
pawn is Unstoppable so after King E4 A4
by Magnus but now Vincent finds the
Brilliance that saves the game and that
is Pawn to H6 now why does this save the
game well the same idea that we've shown
on the previous move no longer applies
spawn to B3 is met with H7 and after
King to G7 stopping promotion there's
Bishop to F6 with check and now you have
to capture otherwise Vincent is getting
a queen king captures on H7 King to D5
now and that's it you start eliminating
everything on the queen side if B2 you
happily give up the best of Knight
captures King captures here and yes you
can play A4 but after King to B4 that's
it you're gonna lose that pawn as well
King G6 you're gonna kick away the
Knight Knight wherever King captures and
it will be a draw by insufficient
material once the uh the F1 is gobbled
up so here came the G6 was played and
now Bishop to E7 Vincent misses this
incredible idea but he was only down to
a few seconds on the clock he has to
continue with the pawn to H7 and well
transpose into the line that we've just
discussed King to D5 B3 and Bishop to F6
and it's the same line however Bishop t7
was played and now Magnus is completely
winning but you have to find this it's
not an easy move to find uh and uh well
uh what would you play here feel free to
pause the video and to win the game for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game as usual and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course Pawn to B3 this is
the move that wins because after King to
D3 there's Knight to E3 and now the C2
square is unavailable to the to the
white king and also the C4 square and
also the C3 Square because of a tactic
and if you don't go there you you will
be on uh um well just uh unable to stop
the pass Pawn if you go here Knight to
the D5 check wins the bishop and then
black is of course just completely
winning but even Magnus misses this he
doesn't go for knight uh for B3 he goes
Knight to D2 with check King to D3 and
now Knight to B3 but now King to C4 we
have Pawn to A4 and now Vincent plays
This brilliant Bishop to G5 move with
Bishop to f8 defending the pawn Magnus
still has chances but after Bishop to G5
uh it's now a dead draw uh of course uh
you know if if everyone plays the
absolute best move if you capture of
course the H Pawn marches forward so
Pawn King to H7 was played and now
Bishop to E3 now Vincent is ready to
collect those pawns Knights to D4 and
now King captures and C5 with Fanta A3
uh Bishop to C1 another spectacular move
and now the problem is if you play
Bishop to B3 check it's not that Vincent
blunder the fork this is the only move
that draws him the game Knight the B3
check King capture zombie for Knight
captures and C1 King captures an A3 and
then the black king just gobbles up
those pawns and that's it so after
Bishop to C1 uh Magnus tried this final
idea of Knight to E2 but it is again
insufficient King Captain B4 Knight
captures and C1 and King characters and
A3 and he was in this position and move
55 that the players agreed to a draw as
there is no way to push for anything
here the pawns will easily get
eliminated by the king or by the Knight
doesn't really matter and that is it
first two rapid games end in a draw
after I mean absolutely a stunning this
display of what could have been Magnus
had a definitely winning chances in the
first game he was up upon well just
completely winning and in the second
game so many so many crazy lines where
he could have won but in the end both
the games are a draw and Vincent leaves
the fight another day we'll see what
happens in the fast or rapid time format
but that's it for uh for for the two
games I would like to thank my wife beat
any wife at chess Angus Cunningham Peter
booth nagarjuna punggoti and Philly past
uh hangstenberg for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the tie breaks uh
well until until they finish so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day